Pinky, are you pondering what I'm pondering?
I think so Brain but, how can you have a Duck Dynasty if none of the people are ducks?
God dammit Pinky, can't you get at least one f**king thing right?
Wha-?
No no, cut the music! Cut the music!
I've put up with this bullshit for too long!
Bullshit?
You are the syphilis to everything I've worked so hard for!
You miserable poisonous sack of disease!
But Brain...
Shut it bitch!
Ahhhh...
I could've had the world years ago if you didn't keep
F**KING IT UP!
Oh dear...
Do me a favor and just
Just die! Just DIE for the sake of all humanity
Ohh Brian...
Oh yes. That's right. Cry!
Oh that's all your good for isn't it!
You little shit!
W-W-Wait a second, wait a second
What?
Are you sure this is for a kids' show?
Just say it, people have wanted to hear this for years.
Oh really? Alright. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Alright.
You are PESTILENCE!
(bawling)
That's right! You're the pestilence of life!
I don't usually believe in homicide.
But if I could go back in time to the moment of your conception...
AAAAHHHHH!